ce sont des endroits dans ce pays où les gens
ne peuvent pas aller sans craindre d'être volés des
meurtres à la tasse nous n'acceptons pas cela dans d'autres
pays pourquoi devrions-nous accepter qu'ici
plus d'une douzaine de membres de gangs sont morts et
ce qui ne peut être décrit que comme un massacre
je  Je veux savoir est-ce que son nom est le
colonel Robert Sykes, il est formé pour
manipuler et combattre les armes à feu, les armes à feu et
les besoins explosifs en utilisant ces compétences pour poursuivre les
gangs ou les trafiquants de drogue pour toute
personne menacée de bien-être dans ce
pays, le
colonel Sikes traquait les
terroristes en Afghanistan est  une femme et un
petit garçon ont été tués dans la fusillade en voiture,
vous semblez en savoir beaucoup sur ce
colonel Sikes, alors qu'est-ce qui vous rend si
qualifié,
j'ai été dans ces endroits avec lui
comme au bon vieux temps, hein, il vous a sauvé la
vie  pas prêté serment de défendre notre
pays contre tous les ennemis,
quelqu'un doit commencer d'une manière ou d'une autre à essayer de
faire une différence si je suis le méchant
qu'est-ce que ça fait merci il y a du vrai
et du faux et les lois sont censées
nous servir tr  uth est la vérité subjective est
absolue les gens sont subjectifs Je vais rendre
cela facile mon doigt sort de ce
détonateur
tout le monde Gong guy
la seule façon de l'arrêter est de devenir
vivant pour dire que personne ne savait que tu n'étais pas venu
c'est différent entre vous
vous